[Music]  good keeping it together a home fans  have been missing Carrie Underwood and  the singer made a powerful return Sunday  night at the 2018 Academy of Country  Music Awards on CBS  [Music]  [Applause]  that's her new single cry pretty singing  solo Carrie captivated the audience and  got a standing ovation it was only about  five months earlier that the 35 year old  superstar fell downstairs at her home  fans knew she had hurt her wrist and  Underwood laid low then in January she  revealed the fall had also hurt her face  that she had needed dozens of stitches  and might look a little different when  they saw her next but Sunday night  Underwood was as poised and powerful as  ever she also won an award for vocal  event of the year with Keith Urban and  she appeared touched by the support